الوضع في غزة اليوم
كارثة. يجب على الكونجرس أن يتخذ إجراءً. يجب على
الإدارة أن تتخذ إجراءً. يجب على
العالم أن يتحرك اليوم بعد 3 أسابيع من
الهجوم الوحشي الذي شنته حماس ضد
المدنيين في إسرائيل والذي بدأ هذه الحرب.
مئات الآلاف من
الرجال والنساء والأطفال الأبرياء في غزة هم ضحايا  على
حافة الهاوية خلال الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية،
تشير التقديرات إلى أن حوالي
8,000 شخص في غزة قتلوا في
القصف، بما في ذلك أكثر من 3,000
طفل وجرح أكثر بكثير، كما
تم تهجير أكثر من مليون شخص في غزة من منازلهم وحوالي
670,000 شخص في عداد المفقودين.  يلجأون إلى منشآت الأمم المتحدة
حيث يحصلون على
لتر واحد من الماء (لتر واحد من الماء للشخص الواحد
يوميًا) ويفتقرون إلى ما يكفي من الغذاء
والماء والإمدادات الطبية أو وقود
المستشفيات والمرافق الطبية
هناك في ظروف مروعة مع
مئات الأطفال في الحاضنات
والمرضى على قيد الحياة  الدعم معرض لخطر
الموت في حالة نفاد الوقود من المولدات التي
تدعمهم. يجب على المدن المتوافقة مع
الجرحى والنازحين
والأطباء المثقلين أن يرفضوا المرضى
أو يقومون بإجراء العمليات الجراحية دون تخدير أو
مضادات حيوية، فالأزمة الإنسانية
وخيمة وتزداد سوءًا في كل دقيقة.
هدنة إنسانية الآن
حتى تتمكن الإمدادات الكافية من الغذاء والماء
والوقود الطبي من الوصول إلى سكان
غزة، إن لم يكن هناك آلاف آخرين سيموتون
دون داع، فلا يمكننا أن نسمح بحدوث ذلك، فإيقاف
عملية Bing أمر بالغ الأهمية لإنقاذ
أرواح الأبرياء وتأمين
العودة الآمنة للرهائن